[Musica]
chi di voi sa cos'è la resilienza la
resilienza è una caratteristica dei
materiali metallici che se sottoposte a
un forte urto non si rompono e riescono
a tornare nella loro condizione iniziale
questo è ciò che ho appreso sui libri
studiando ingegneria avevo compreso del
tutto questa definizione non ne sono
certa forse l'avevo compresa solo in
teoria perché un giorno ho conosciuto un
altro significato di questa parola
il riprendere in mano la propria vita
davanti a situazioni difficili con forza
e con coraggio ovvero il coraggio di non
aver paura
era il 5 aprile 2009 e come tante altre
a lumenick e ero rimasta a l'aquila per
preparare un esame
vivevo in un appartamento in affitto al
piano rialzato di un palazzo di cinque
piani
quella sera chiacchieravo in cucina con
le mie amiche coinquiline del più e del
meno dei nostri amori programmavamo le
nostre serate universitarie le nostre
core7 per rimanere in forma
la normale vita di ragazza
ventiquattrenne dopo esserci salutate
sul corridoio ci siamo date la
buonanotte e ognuna di noi è rientrata
nella propria camera alle 23 la prima
forte scossa spaventate ci siamo
reincontrati su quello stesso corridoio
dove fino a poco tempo prima stavamo
chiacchierando di cose leggere futili
per controllare che la casa stesse bene
al terremoto ci stavamo abituando a
l'aquila le scosse si susseguivano da
diverse settimane e tutti ci dicevano
che potevamo stare tranquilli che era un
po come vivere in giappone ma in realtà
le case erano un po differenti dopo aver
verificato che l'appartamento stesse
bene
ancora una volta per la seconda volta ci
siamo date la buonanotte
mai avrei immaginato che quello sarebbe
stato l'ultimo saluto alle mie amiche
rientrata in camera di impulso come mai
avevo fatto prima
ho spostato il letto vicino alla
finestra mi aiutava poter pensare di
avere una figlia con una via di fuga in
più la finestra e la porta qualora ce ne
fosse stato bisogno mi faceva sentire
più tranquilla certo riaddormentarsi non
è stato semplice
c'è voluta una buona lettura ma alla
fine ce l'ho fatta
alle 3 32 un terribile boato i
calcinacci che scendevano giù le urla
prima e il silenzio poi il palazzo in
cui viveva era totalmente crollato ed io
ero lì sotto sola in silenzio e al buio
sentivo solo il battito del mio cuore
che riusciva a rompere il silenzio
provate a immaginare
sono rimasta lì sotto per ben 23 ore le
prime otto totalmente sola con le mie
ansie e le mie crescenti paure
dopo un primo momento di disorientamento
iniziale in cui non riuscivo a capire se
ero viva 0 morta sera tutto solo un
brutto sogno
ho cercato di pensare a che cosa avrei
potuto e dovuto fare per sopravvivere o
sfoderato un sangue freddo che mai avrei
immaginato avere cercavo di trattenere
le urine per paura di rimanere
disidratata facevo economia d aria
cercavo di respirare piano per rimanere
più tranquilla sembra uno stranissimo
esercizio di meditazione il tempo
passava però io iniziavo a perdere la
cognizione alle 7 30 come ogni mattina
sono la sveglia del mio cellulare le 730
e 740 le 750 sembrava volesse dirmi
marta svegliati e tardi devi andare
all'università ogni 10 minuti si
ripeteva quanto avrei voluto dar retta a
quel suono che tante altre volte in
passato avevo diato ma come potevo ero
totalmente intrappolata ero totalmente
bloccate iniziavo davvero ad aver paura
tuttavia le ore passavano finalmente
sento una voce è quella di antec di
antonella la speleologa che mi ha
identificato la sento gridare c6 ci
siete
ed io rispondo sì ci sono ci siamo siamo
in cinque io mi chiamo marta valente per
favore dite alla mia famiglia che sono
viva e mi trovo in corrispondenza della
quarta finestra le altre ragazze si
trovano in corrispondenza della prima
della seconda della terza e della quinta
finestra cercavo di dare quante più
indicazioni utili possibili
non avevo capito che i miei suggerimenti
che erano del tutto inutili le mie
amiche il palazzo le finestre non
c'erano più
dal momento in cui soccorritori ne hanno
identificate sono passate 15 ore 15 ore
ricche di paure i timori ma anche ricche
di speranza ora in cui mi sentivo
impotente in cui l'unico contatto che
avevo con il mondo esterno
era la mia mano stretta alla loro ci
sono voluti quindici ore 15 ore per
estrarmi ma dopo 23 ore i soccorritori
del soccorso alpino e speleologico mi
hanno riportato alla luce e lo salva
grazie a loro e con loro
7 aprile 2009
e questa è questo l'inizio della mia
seconda vita è questa la data della mia
rinascita
e stata una rinascita nel vero senso
della parola
102 giorni di ricovero ospedaliero ore e
ore di rianimazione giorni di
riabilitazione fisica e psicologica
ero tornata una neonata a tutti gli
effetti allettata con il pannolone
alimentata con una cannuccia che mia
madre amorevolmente mi poggiava sulle
labbra come fosse biberon di un tempo
avevo perso tutto
avevo perso le mie amiche avevo perso
tutto ciò che di materiale possedevo
libri scarpe vestiti computer
avevo perso la mia quotidianità
tuttavia per me ogni giorno era una
conquista tante cose che apparentemente
fanno parte della nostra quotidianità
per me avevano acquisito un valore
speciale rivedere il cielo osservare gli
alberi ascoltare il rumore della natura
avevano tutt'altro sapore
ma avevo ancora una grande difficoltà ad
affrontare dovevo tornare a camminare
gli esami medici dicevano che non ce
l'avrei fatta
lo diceva la scienza io non volevo
credere a questi referti è vero avevo
perso il movimento e la sensibilità alle
gambe ma li avevo ancora in tutto il
resto del mio corpo è nel mio cuore ho
lottato combattuto mi sono rialzata e
sono caduta così tante volte di aver
perso il conto
ma alla fine ce l'ho fatta sono tornata
a camminare con le mie gambe ed oggi
sono qui e indosso anche i tacchi
[Applauso]
avevo una motivazione pazzesca a 24 anni
non conosce il significato di parole
come sosta pausa riposo vorresti
spaccare il mondo
ero determinata non solo nel tornare a
camminare ma anche nel riprendere in
mano il mio percorso accademico così a
settembre 2009
ho chiesto un permesso per uscire dal
mondo ovattato e protetto dell'ospedale
per tornare all'aquila a sostenere un
esame
quello stesso esame per cui stavo
studiando il 5 aprile 2009 è stata un
esame speciale ricco di significati l'ho
sostenuto sotto le tende insieme a tante
altre persone che come me
stavano ricostruendo la loro vita ho
preso 30
[Applauso]
un anno dopo mi sono laureata in
ingegneria gestionale con 110 lode è una
speciale menzione da parte della
commissione per essermi distinta nel mio
percorso di studi sempre all'aquila mi
sono laureata da questa esperienza ho
imparato che il terremoto è una grande
forza della natura ma è la natura stessa
che ha donato a tutti noi una potenza
altrettanto grande la nostra mente e lo
so cuore
sta a noi scegliere come usare questa
intelligenza
io ho cercato di trasformare questo
grande dolore in qualcosa di positivo
ho cercato di trasformare il dono che ho
avuto dalla vita stessa ossia la vita in
qualcosa che potesse essere dono nel
mondo speranza nella collettività
ho scelto di diventare coach
motivazionale con l'obiettivo di aiutare
gli altri e supportarli
ho iniziato a viaggiare di più a
conoscere quella natura così beffarda
che tanto mi aveva tolto ma che tanto
continua a donarmi con le ciaspole a
cavallo con l'escursionismo ho iniziato
a dare un'importanza diversa al tempo e
alle relazioni godendo di ogni altimo
disposizione ho iniziato a svolgere
attività di volontariato con il credo
che il donare amore agli altri è una
terapia potentissima oggi il mondo lo
vedo lo vivo con occhi diversi
ho conosciuto un mondo in cui imparare
in cui sognare in cui credere
penso che ognuno di noi nella propria
vita nella propria quotidianità si trovi
a vivere dei momenti difficili dei
momenti di buio dei momenti di silenzio
ma è proprio in questi che si cresce e
proprio in questi che si sceglie chi si
vuole essere e come si vuole essere e
allora si può disegnare la propria vita
ho dato un nome a questa esperienza
le olimpiadi della vita in tanti mi
dicono che ho vinto la medaglia d'oro e
probabilmente ci sono riuscita perché ho
lottato ho combattuto con pazienza
tenacia determinazione
e resilienza ed oggi affronta la mia
quotidianità con il sorriso con gioia e
con amore
tante piccole cose che se messe insieme
diventano medicine per l'anima e fanno
nascere spontaneo un pensiero rispetto
alla vita vale la pena viverla
e allora sì che ognuno di noi può
iniziare a disegnare il proprio quadro e
colorarlo con colori intensi vivaci e
luminosi grazie
[Applauso]